Florida set to dramatically expand its
don't say gay laws here's what they will
do this is Time magazine article
obviously uh or else it has nothing to
do with don't say gay laws that's just
what they're promoting Republicans
lawmakers in Florida are planning to
expand
Provisions in their parental rights and
Education Act or don't say gay law which
will restrict what teachers can and
cannot say in their classrooms about
gender sex and sexual orientation the
bill would heavily restrict in-school
discussions about sexual orientation or
gender identity until ninth grade and
Bad Teacher banned teachers from
addressing students by pronouns that
differ from those they were assigned at
Birth the advocates for and against
these bills that time spoke to believe
this legislation will pass lgbtq and
Advocate plus Advocates especially fear
that the bill would have adverse effects
on lgbtq families and more than 16 000
Florida youth that identify as
transgender research by The Williams
Institute at the UCLA School of Law
found that more than half of the lgbtq
parents surveyed considered moving out
of Florida because of the don't say gay
law jet would you be heartbroken if
these parents left Florida leave see you
later bye don't let the door hit you on
the way out no this is why it's
important to choose where you live right
now this is why I'm at state to state
you see massive differences by the way
in terms of what Governors are and
aren't willing to tackle I mean look at
what we just saw there they want what
third graders getting this information
that is talking about up until ninth
grade they're trying to make stuff age
appropriate for kids they're also trying
to say if you're a boy you can't just
leave the house at home a boy and
everybody's you know oh this is Jimmy
and then you go to school and somebody
calls you a girl all day long the
parents don't know about it nobody knows
what's going on these are parental
rights bills these are places that you
can live by the way States like Florida
and and there are a lot of red States
some red states by the way are slacking
behind on this stuff but there are a lot
of red States you can go to and you just
know listen if something's going on with
my kid as a parent the school is going
to inform me my kid's not going to have
a whole separate life at school than
they have at home and there's not going
to be this big black hole of nonsense
going on at school that's completely
inappropriate for my eighth grader let's
say totally normal anybody with their
head on straight would not have a
problem with this stuff
Frank
um I I love the parental rights and
education bill I think it would do
tremendous positive things for my
community when it comes to addressing
kids by their pronouns you're seeing a
big push of this happen the reason this
law which I'm going to say that I
support if they do implement this is is
they are affirming these genders they
are affirming these pronouns outside of
what their parents are calling them and
so now you don't even have the parents
included in this conversation and
teachers are doing this behind their
back and so you have you know Ron
DeSantis coming in and saying you know
what no you shouldn't be doing this you
shouldn't be guiding you should not be
grooming these children you you should
be referring to them as they were born
because no child the reason gays against
groomer says no child is born in the
wrong body isn't to disavow that gender
dysphoria exists it's to put Force light
on that children do not have the mental
capacity to make these decisions fully
formed and educated decisions so that is
why no child is born in the wrong body
and you can never can well I shouldn't
say you can never but I've worn it
stands right now it's very likely that
you would not be able to convince me
otherwise because children are too
innocent and the reason why that they
are going down this journey is because
of the outside influences and we're
seeing these ramifications like with
that article with children dying I think
that article said six thousand seventy
three hundred yep and it's it's a shame
and you know who that falls on if we
want to blame someone for that that's
going to be on the teachers because the
teachers are affirming these things all
across our country without their parents
knowing and they're not even getting the
the guided assistance that they need
they're just going to school saying hey
Mr Lopez can you call me a she instead
of a he and then Mr Lopez is like sure
and it's like that is so toxic and
dangerous and confusing that you've got
the kids live in two separate lives I
mean talk about confusion and a kid in a
child's mind one thing one whole life at
home as you know Jimmy goes to school
all day gets acknowledged as whatever
now they're thinking of their parents as
the enemy they're confused they don't
know who to trust I mean that is a mess
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here here
[Music]